Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a bi-weekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Drinking is ubiquitous in American culture today. It's hard to go out and not see people imbibing. Alcohol flows freely at brunches, baby showers, and birthday parties, not just in bars. In the midst of all this booze, there is a burgeoning movement in the opposite direction. Sobriety is having a moment in the moment. in the spotlight. For the sober curious crowd, this can mean taking a break from alcohol for a set period, such as during specific months, you may have heard of dry January or sober October, or it can mean quitting altogether. Either way, as our guest for this episode says, stopping drinking even for a short period can be beneficial because it allows us time to explore our relationship with alcohol with a clear head. Today we're talking to addiction researcher and psychologist, Dr. Katie Witkowitz, from the University of New Mexico.
您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。如今，饮酒在美国文化中无处不在。出门在外，很难不看到人们在喝酒。酒精在早午餐、迎婴派对和生日聚会上随处可见，而不仅仅是在酒吧里。在酒精泛滥的背景下，一股相反的潮流正在兴起。清醒生活正成为当下的热门话题，备受关注。对于那些对清醒生活感到好奇的人群来说，这意味着在一段时间内戒酒，比如在特定的月份——你可能听说过“清醒一月”或“清醒十月”——或者意味着彻底戒酒。无论哪种方式，正如我们本期的嘉宾所说，即使是短时间的戒酒也可能是有益的，因为它让我们有时间以清醒的头脑审视自己与酒精的关系。今天，我们采访了新墨西哥大学的成瘾研究员兼心理学家凯蒂·威特科维茨博士。
She's part of the university's Center on Alcoholism, Substance Abuse, and Addictions. Welcome, Dr. Witkowitz. Thank you, Caitlin. It's great to be here. They were really happy to have you on our show today. So first I want to start off with, why do you think alcohol has such a tight grip on American society? Yeah, I think alcohol, there's a quote of it being a pervasive fact of life. And I think that quote really captures alcohol in our society, even since before prohibition,
她是该大学酒精、药物滥用和成瘾中心的研究人员。欢迎您，威特科维茨博士。谢谢你，凯特琳。很高兴来到这里。我们也非常高兴你能参加今天的节目。首先我想问，你认为为什么酒精对美国社会有如此强大的控制力？是的，我认为有一句名言说酒精是生活中无处不在的事实。我认为这句话很好地概括了酒精在我们社会中的地位，甚至在禁酒令之前就是如此，
but especially during and after prohibition. So alcohol is a legal substance, and it's a legal psychoactive drug that in many cases makes people feel better, either in celebration or when they're not feeling good, it can provide some relief of negative feelings and is commonly used in celebration and generally brings people small amounts of joy in their life. And so I think alcohol is a part of. life in part of society because it is a legal psychoactive drug that many people view as as safe, although we could talk about that assumption and that people just generally use to socialize and
但在禁酒令期间和之后尤其明显。酒精是一种合法的物质，也是一种合法的精神活性药物。在许多情况下，它能让人感觉更好，无论是在庆祝时，还是在心情不佳时，它都能缓解负面情绪，通常用于庆祝活动，并能给人们的生活带来少许快乐。所以我认为酒精是生活的一部分，也是社会的一部分，因为它是一种合法的精神活性药物，许多人认为它是安全的——尽管我们可以讨论这种假设——而且人们通常用它来社交和
to have fun and also this other side of helping to relieve distress. So relieving negative states, so negative emotions, relieving pain. It's generally a drug that provides a lot of different potential short-term benefits in the moment. And so given it's legal, it's widely available. It's socially accepted. It's not too surprising that we see alcohol everywhere. And we as a culture, most Americans use alcohol, drink alcohol. Let's explore that presumption of safety because you said it's legal, of course, and it's socially acceptable. So how does that affect people's drinking, knowing that it is, quote unquote, a safe thing to be doing? Yeah. And I think, you know it's interesting because there is a mixed research on even the health benefits of
娱乐，此外它还有缓解痛苦的一面。也就是说，缓解负面状态，比如负面情绪，缓解疼痛。它通常是一种在当下能提供多种潜在短期益处的药物。因此，鉴于它是合法的，且随处可见，又被社会所接受，我们看到酒精无处不在也就不足为奇了。作为一个文化群体，大多数美国人都使用酒精，饮用酒精。让我们探讨一下关于安全性的假设，因为正如你所说，它当然是合法的，而且在社会上是可以接受的。那么，知道它是一种所谓的“安全”行为，是如何影响人们的饮酒习惯的呢？是的，我认为这很有趣，因为关于酒精的健康益处，甚至所谓的健康益处，研究结果是相互矛盾的，
alcohol supposed health benefits of alcohol and so basically there's this assumption that that low levels of drinking are not harmful at all and might even be beneficial for health and so the the research is actually pretty clear on this that the amounts of alcohol that are safe and and potentially even have health benefits is pretty low. And it's pretty low compared to what most people drink. So less than one drink per day is considered a low level of alcohol use and kind of a safe level of alcohol use. And any more than that is potentially associated with health risks.
所以基本上存在这样一种假设：低水平的饮酒完全无害，甚至可能对健康有益。事实上，关于这一点的研究相当明确：安全的、甚至可能对健康有益的酒精摄入量非常低。与大多数人的饮酒量相比，这个量非常低。因此，每天饮酒少于一杯被认为是低水平的酒精使用，也是一种相对安全的酒精使用水平。超过这个量就可能与健康风险相关。
And there are some research suggesting some health benefits of low levels of alcohol use, but increasing research showing that alcohol use, even in low amounts, increases risks for certain cancers, certainly increases risk for liver disease and other disorders. So even low amounts of alcohol, for some conditions, it is not safe. And for the health benefits of alcohol, it is actually a pretty low amount compared to what many people drink, which is more than less than drink a day when they drink. So it's actually, it's not completely healthy to drink alcohol. And we know more and more about the health risks. That said, I think it's a relatively safer drug compared to other drugs, particularly illicit drugs, that can have more significant consequences.
虽然有一些研究表明低水平的饮酒对健康有益，但越来越多的研究表明，即使是少量的酒精摄入也会增加患某些癌症的风险，当然也会增加患肝病和其他疾病的风险。因此，即使是少量的酒精，对于某些疾病来说也是不安全的。至于酒精的健康益处，与许多人饮酒时的摄入量（通常每天超过一杯）相比，这个量实际上非常低。所以，饮酒并不完全健康。我们对健康风险了解得越来越多。话虽如此，我认为与其他药物，特别是可能产生更严重后果的非法药物相比，它是一种相对更安全的药物。
As an addiction researcher, are you alarmed by this by the current drinking trends you see in America? Yes, I am, especially given increases in certain segments. I'm actually most concerned about increasing drinking among older adults and among women, where we see actually in recent years greater increases in drinking. And it's alarming to me because, you know, there is this social acceptability and there's also treatments available that work, but a lot of people aren't actually getting treatments that they need, are not seeking treatment, are not getting help. And I think our society as a whole would really benefit from starting to have a conversation about the benefits of reducing drinking.
作为一名成瘾研究员，你对美国目前的饮酒趋势感到担忧吗？是的，我感到担忧，特别是考虑到某些群体中饮酒量的增加。我实际上最担心的是老年人和女性饮酒量的增加，近年来我们看到这两个群体的饮酒量增长幅度更大。这让我感到担忧，因为虽然存在社会认可度，也有行之有效的治疗方法，但许多人实际上并没有得到他们需要的治疗，没有寻求治疗，也没有获得帮助。我认为，如果我们整个社会能开始讨论减少饮酒的好处，将会大有裨益。
And what we know is that it's kind of both things are true. So if any drinking increases your risk of certain health conditions, health diseases, health disorders, that reductions in drinking considerably improves health. And so I really want to, I would love for our society to actually flip the conversation to be really more focused on the benefits, the health benefits of reductions in drinking. And I think about it, because it is legal and socially accepted, I really think of drinking alcohol as similar to any other health behavior. And so I think about, I often use the comparison of eating fried food, right?
我们所知道的是，这两者在某种程度上都是事实。如果任何饮酒行为都会增加你患某些健康状况、疾病和失调的风险，那么减少饮酒则会显著改善健康。所以我真的希望，我非常希望我们的社会能转变话题，真正更多地关注减少饮酒带来的健康益处。我经常思考这个问题，因为酒精是合法的且被社会接受的，我真的认为饮酒与其他任何健康行为类似。所以我经常用吃油炸食品来做比较，对吧？
So we know that eating fried food is not great for us, but it's legal and it's generally socially acceptable. And it's not super healthy to eat fried food. And probably a little bit of fried food is not super harmful to health. But as you increase your amount of fried food intake, you're increasing the health. risk of eating fried food. And I think as a society, at this point, many people are on board with the idea that we should reduce our fried food intake, right, that we shouldn't be having, you know, the supersized French fries at every single meal. And so I would love for us to have a similar kind of thinking about kind of the health risks and benefits of alcohol and thinking similarly
我们知道吃油炸食品对我们不好，但它是合法的，而且通常在社会上是可以接受的。吃油炸食品并不太健康。可能少吃一点油炸食品对健康危害不大。但随着你油炸食品摄入量的增加，你患病的风险也在增加。我认为作为一个社会，在这一点上，许多人已经认同我们应该减少油炸食品摄入量的观点，对吧？我们不应该在每一顿饭都吃超大份的炸薯条。所以我希望我们能对酒精的健康风险和益处有类似的思考，并同样认为
around reducing alcohol use as important as a society. And instead, our society, our society actually kind of glorifies and glamorizes heavy drinking. And that to me is concerning. How have you seen that patterns of drinking change? Because we obviously know the history of drinking of alcohol in America, the prohibition movement, and then also the three martini lunch that was popular a couple decades ago. And, you know, you see a TV show like Mad Men where it seems like people are spending every day at work, you know, under the influence of alcohol or drunk, whatever, however you want to call it. What have you seen in trends in America? Yeah. And I think, you know, it's interesting. The rates of alcohol use have been, you know, they decreased with prohibition.
在社会层面减少酒精使用非常重要。然而，我们的社会实际上在某种程度上美化和粉饰了酗酒行为。这让我感到担忧。你观察到的饮酒模式发生了怎样的变化？因为我们显然了解美国饮酒的历史、禁酒运动，以及几十年前流行的“三杯马提尼午餐”。而且，你看像《广告狂人》这样的电视剧，人们似乎每天都在工作时处于酒精的影响下，或者喝醉了，无论你怎么称呼它。你在美国的趋势中看到了什么？是的，我认为这很有趣。酒精的使用率在禁酒令期间确实有所下降。
Prohibition was effective in reducing rates of alcohol use. They increased to really pretty quickly to pre-prohibition levels shortly after prohibition. And so once alcohol became legal again, there was a steady increase in drinking and then drinking. pretty quickly matched the pre-prohibition levels of drinking. There was a decline in drinking prior to prohibition that's important to note because states rolled out different dry laws prior to even prohibition happening. So there was a decrease in drinking than prohibition, the large decrease in drinking, and then after prohibition and increase in drinking. And since that time, alcohol use has remained relatively stable in many segments of society. There's been some increases among
禁酒令在降低酒精使用率方面是有效的。禁酒令结束后不久，酒精使用率很快就回升到了禁酒令前的水平。因此，一旦酒精再次合法化，饮酒量就稳步上升，并很快达到了禁酒令前的水平。值得注意的是，在禁酒令之前饮酒量确实有所下降，因为各州在禁酒令实施之前就推出了不同的禁酒法。所以，先是饮酒量下降，然后是禁酒令带来的大幅下降，之后是禁酒令后的饮酒量回升。从那时起，酒精的使用在社会的许多阶层中保持相对稳定。在70年代和80年代，
young adult drinking that occurred in the 70s and 80s. And more recently, we're seeing increases in drinking among older adults and women, as I mentioned. And I think the important thing to know, though, even back to the 70s, but certainly today, the characterizations of alcohol use in the media is really wrong. You know, most people who drink alcohol in our society do not drink at very heavy levels. And that's been true for many years. The majority of people do not drink heavily. And it's only about 30% of people who engage in what we would, people in the U.S. currently,
年轻人的饮酒量有所增加。而最近，正如我提到的，我们看到老年人和女性的饮酒量在增加。但我认为重要的一点是，即使追溯到70年代，当然也包括今天，媒体对酒精使用的描述是非常错误的。你知道，在我们社会中，大多数饮酒的人并没有达到酗酒的程度。这种情况已经持续了很多年。大多数人并不酗酒。只有大约30%的美国人目前，
who engage in what we would call heavy drinking, which is defined as more than four drinks in an occasion for women, four or more drinks in an occasion for women and five or more drinks on an occasion for men. So only about 30% of people are drinking at that high level occasionally. Most people, when they drink alcohol, do not drink as much as the media would portray alcohol to be consumed. Why do you think alcohol use has increased in older Americans and women? I think it's a lot of interesting factors that go into the increase in drinking among both older adults and women. You know, there's been a lot of research lately on kind of ideas around disorders of despair that just generally as Americans, a lot of factors play into this, and we could spend several hours talking about them,
参与我们所说的“酗酒”，即女性单次饮酒超过四杯，男性单次饮酒超过五杯。所以只有大约30%的人偶尔会达到这种高水平的饮酒。大多数人在饮酒时，并没有达到媒体所描绘的那种消费量。你认为为什么美国老年人和女性的酒精使用量会增加？我认为导致老年人和女性饮酒量增加的因素有很多，非常有趣。你知道，最近有很多关于“绝望疾病”的研究，总的来说，作为美国人，很多因素都参与其中，我们可以花几个小时来讨论它们，
you know, increase social media use, increase news, 24-hour news cycle, increase in just daily stressors of society, and people living older and longer, living older and longer alone, divorce is more common. There's just a lot of social stressors right now, and women in particular are, especially the group that's increasing their drinking, which is middle-aged to older women are increasingly being stressed on both sides. So more and more women are, you know, playing multiple roles, both in the workforce, in the home, but also being stretched to be taking care of older parents, as well as taking care of children in many cases. And so there's a lot of stress right now in these populations. And alcohol is a pretty effective stress reliever in the
比如社交媒体使用量的增加、24小时新闻循环、社会日常压力的增加，以及人们寿命的延长，独自生活的老年人增多，离婚变得更加普遍。现在确实有很多社会压力，尤其是女性，特别是那些饮酒量正在增加的群体，即中年到老年女性，她们正承受着来自各方面的压力。越来越多的女性在职场和家庭中扮演多重角色，同时还要照顾年迈的父母，在许多情况下还要照顾孩子。所以这些人群现在承受着很大的压力。而酒精在短期内是一种相当有效的减压剂。
short term. And many people come to use alcohol to relieve stress because it is effective in the short term. It's not a long-term solution. And that's where kind of getting into help comes in. At the same time, it is effective in the short term. So more people are turning to alcohol, which again is legal, it's socially acceptable. It's everywhere, as you noted in the beginning of this. And so I think more people are turning to alcohol to relieve what is an increasingly stress. world. Turning this up to the completely opposite direction, why do you think the sobriety movement, the sober curious movement, whatever you want to call it, why do you think it's catching on? Yeah. Well, I'm just thrilled about it. And I have to say, I think it's wonderful for us to be
许多人开始使用酒精来缓解压力，因为它在短期内确实有效。但它不是长期的解决方案。这就是寻求帮助的意义所在。同时，它在短期内确实有效。所以更多的人转向酒精，正如你在一开始提到的，酒精是合法的，在社会上是可以接受的，它无处不在。所以我认为更多的人正在转向酒精来缓解这个日益充满压力的世界。转到完全相反的方向，你认为为什么清醒运动、清醒好奇运动，或者无论你怎么称呼它，为什么会流行起来？是的。嗯，我对此感到非常激动。我必须说，我认为我们开始认识到
kind of starting to recognize that not everyone has to drink heavily. Not everyone has to drink. and really shifting the conversation to be focusing on, wait, we as a society could make an effort to reduce our drinking and even, you know, not drink at all. And so I think, frankly, a lot of people are also a little bit fed up with drinking. I mean, when you really look at alcohol use, particularly when you're talking about heavy alcohol consumption, there's hangovers, there's worries about violating laws and consequences of heavy drinking. There's There's just the health effects of continual heavy drinking. So, you know, a lot of time in the holidays, people will just say like, oh, I just, like,
并不是每个人都必须酗酒，甚至并不是每个人都必须饮酒，这真是太好了。我们真正将话题转向关注：等等，我们作为一个社会可以努力减少饮酒，甚至可以完全不饮酒。所以坦率地说，我认为很多人也对饮酒感到有点厌倦了。我的意思是，当你真正审视酒精的使用，特别是当你谈论大量饮酒时，会有宿醉，会有担心违反法律和酗酒后果的忧虑。还有持续酗酒对健康的损害。所以，你知道，在假期里，人们经常会说，哦，我只是，
every day has been a party and I've been drinking so much and I just feel like I need a break. And so I think it's wonderful that we would normalize and create a society, a culture that actually supports sober, sober choices, supports non-drinking choices, non-drinking activities. and what's been happening lately is people kind of joining together to choose to not drink. And there's a social component to that that I think is really important. And so I really think that people are starting to just kind of question, hey, is this drink, drink, drink, culture really what we want? Are we getting what we want out of it?
每一天都在聚会，我喝得太多了，我觉得我需要休息一下。所以我认为，如果我们能使清醒的选择、非饮酒的选择和非饮酒的活动正常化，并创造一个支持这些选择的社会和文化，那真是太好了。最近发生的事情是，人们开始联合起来选择不喝酒。我认为这其中的社交成分非常重要。所以我真的认为人们开始质疑：嘿，这种“喝、喝、喝”的文化真的是我们想要的吗？我们从中得到了我们想要的吗？
And a lot of people are answering that questions with maybe not. Like I'm having consequences. I'm hungover. I don't feel well. I'm saying things I don't want to say. I'm, you know, maybe having relationships with people I don't want to have relationships with. My life is revolving around alcohol and I want other options. And I think it's great.
很多人对这些问题的回答可能是“不”。比如，我正在承受后果。我宿醉了。我感觉不好。我说了我不该说的话。我可能正在与我不希望有关系的人建立关系。我的生活围绕着酒精，我想要其他的选择。我认为这很好。
I think that's why this is catching on because there are other options. We don't have to only drink. And a lot of people know that. A lot of people have already discovered that. But I think the people who are kind of drawn to this sober curious crowd or this sobriety movement are people who've kind of filled their life with a lot of drinking activities and are now evaluating whether that's what they really want. Yeah, and to that end, there are some sober bars, if you will, however it's which way you want to call it. But these bars that only serve non-alcoholic drinks, and we're seeing a lot of really creative mocktails showing up on bar menus and restaurants. Do you think this, seeing all these options out there, does this make the sober curious crowd or someone who's just taking a break feel more comfortable because it's not like they just have to sit there and sip water?
我认为这就是它流行的原因，因为还有其他的选择。我们不必只喝酒。很多人都知道这一点。很多人已经发现了这一点。但我认为那些被这种“清醒好奇”人群或清醒运动所吸引的人，是那些曾经用大量饮酒活动填满生活，现在正在评估这是否真的是他们想要的人。是的，为此，有一些所谓的“清醒酒吧”，无论你怎么称呼它。但这些酒吧只供应无酒精饮料，我们看到酒吧菜单和餐厅里出现了许多非常有创意的无酒精鸡尾酒。你认为看到这些选择，会让“清醒好奇”的人群或只是想休息一下的人感到更自在吗？因为他们不必只是坐在那里喝水，
They can have a nice, tasty drink. They don't feel left out of just having a good beverage. Definitely. Yeah, I think that that's one of the really hard things for individuals who want to not drink is they want to be in a social environment with other people, friends, colleagues, after work, family members. And oftentimes in those settings for years, the only choice has been like water soda, which a lot of people don't want to drink for the sugar or alcohol. And it really sets up an environment where people then become uncomfortable. They don't want to be. drinking water or soda all night. And so these mocktails or these these really creative avenues for having a setting, a social setting where people can engage in non-drinking of alcohol, but still be in that environment and feel like they're having something good and rewarding, especially they do. They're kind of these fun mocktails with like fun names and they're expensive. And they actually like kind of mimic that experience of a reward of having some sort of kind of treat that that you're
他们可以喝上一杯美味的饮料。他们不会因为没有喝到好饮料而感到被冷落。绝对是这样。是的，我认为对于那些想要戒酒的人来说，最困难的事情之一就是他们想在社交环境中与其他人、朋友、同事、下班后的伙伴、家人在一起。多年来，在这些场合，唯一的选择通常是水或苏打水，很多人因为糖分或酒精的原因不想喝这些。这确实造成了一种环境，让人们感到不舒服。他们不想整晚都喝水或苏打水。所以这些无酒精鸡尾酒，或者这些非常有创意的社交环境，让人们可以在不饮酒的情况下参与其中，但仍然身处那种环境，并感觉自己正在享用某种美好且有回报的东西，特别是它们确实如此。它们就像那些有趣的无酒精鸡尾酒，有有趣的名字，而且价格不菲。它们实际上模仿了那种享用某种“款待”的体验，
going to have and that you're going to savor and really enjoy instead of just, you know, downing some ice water in the company of people who are drinking these fun flavored drinks. Yeah, and there's also people who I call sober evangelists out there who've written books. I'm thinking, Holly Whitaker who wrote, quit like a woman and Ruby Warrington who wrote Sober Curious, The Blissful Sleep, Greater Focus, Limitless Presence and Deep Connection, awaiting us all on the other side of alcohol, quite a mouthful. So there are people out there in this space who are promoting the message of sobriety. And, you know, interestingly, as we touched on earlier, a lot of this caters to women. So what are your thoughts
你会细细品味并真正享受它，而不是仅仅在喝着这些有趣风味饮料的人群中灌下一些冰水。是的，还有一些我称之为“清醒传道者”的人，他们写了书。我想到的是写了《像女人一样戒酒》的霍莉·惠特克，以及写了《清醒好奇：酒精另一端的幸福睡眠、更强专注力、无限存在感和深度连接》的鲁比·沃灵顿，这书名真长。所以在这个领域里，有人正在推广清醒的信息。而且，有趣的是，正如我们之前提到的，这其中很多内容是针对女性的。那么你对
about this movement out there where people are having these sober role models? Yeah, I think, I think it's wonderful. I think, again, as you noted, alcohol use is increasing among women, or as we've been talking about, alcohol use is increasing among women. It's really part of another culture that at least I hear about in the work that I do of, you know, these, like, for example, there's these wine and art classes where you, you know, you go and paint paintings and I think it has a funny name. Maybe you know it. I don't know it. But you go and like, you do paintings with, you know, with your friends and then you're drinking alcohol or book club. Oh my gosh. I know. I was in a book club in graduate school and it was really about drinking a bunch of wine with my
这个运动中人们拥有这些清醒榜样有什么看法？是的，我认为这太棒了。我认为，正如你所指出的，女性的酒精使用量正在增加，或者正如我们一直在讨论的，女性的酒精使用量正在增加。这确实是另一种文化的一部分，至少我在我的工作中听说过，比如，有这些“红酒与艺术”课程，你去画画，我想它有一个有趣的名字。也许你知道。我不知道。但你和朋友一起去画画，然后你在喝酒，或者读书俱乐部。天哪。我知道。我在研究生院时参加过一个读书俱乐部，它实际上就是和我的
female friends. Occasionally I would read the book. But so book club or these like art classes or just getting together for brunch and, you know, mimosa brunch and having having several mimosas. So I think women have been really pulled into this with these other activities that really don't necessarily need alcohol. Like you're doing this other thing that's that's also really enjoyable. And so I think another piece of this is that women have generally been left out. of treatment and research and kind of thinking about alcohol use disorder. It's up until recently, it's primarily been a male disorder. I mean, the majority of people in earlier clinical trials for alcohol use disorder, for example, were men, Alcoholics Anonymous, is, as another example,
女性朋友一起喝大量的红酒。偶尔我会读那本书。但读书俱乐部，或者这些艺术课程，或者只是聚在一起吃早午餐，喝几杯含羞草鸡尾酒。所以我认为女性确实被这些活动拉进去了，而这些活动并不一定需要酒精。就像你在做其他同样非常令人愉快的事情一样。所以我认为这其中的另一个部分是，女性通常被排除在
is very male-dominated. It's very, it was created by men. It used to be kind of a men's group, and the wives were supporting the men in their path to sobriety. So it's really only recently that that alcohol use disorder is increased among women, that alcohol use has become socially acceptable among women, that alcohol use is encouraged among women, and even drinks, types that are coming out to really cater to women. So these kind of so-called low-calorie, like the hard selters, the drinks that specifically advertise and market to women. And so you've seen this increase of women being targeted by the alcohol industry, of women increasingly engaging in alcohol use. I think it's absolutely wonderful that women are also leading the charge and kind of providing some other ways
治疗和研究以及对酒精使用障碍的思考之外。直到最近，它主要还是一种男性疾病。我的意思是，在早期的酒精使用障碍临床试验中，大多数参与者是男性，“匿名戒酒互助会”是另一个例子，
to think about how to reduce drinking and kind of reevaluate alcohol's use in your life. I often think about someone with an alcohol use disorder as someone who drinks excessively all the time. And I don't think I'm alone in that. But I was reading an article from the Cleveland Clinic that said the definition of an alcohol use disorder is being unable to stop despite negative consequences. And that threshold could be one drink a night or one drink a week. So that was really interesting to me that it wasn't necessarily a physical dependence. It wasn't your drinking 10 drinks a day. It was like it could just mean you need to have, you feel like you need to have that nightly glass of wine. Yeah, exactly. And I think another problem with our society that I love,
它非常男性主导。它是由男性创建的。它过去是一种男性团体，妻子们在支持丈夫的清醒之路。所以直到最近，酒精使用障碍在女性中增加，酒精使用在女性中变得社会可接受，酒精使用在女性中受到鼓励，甚至出现了专门迎合女性的饮料类型。比如那些所谓的低卡路里饮料，像硬苏打水，专门针对女性进行广告和营销的饮料。所以你已经看到了女性被酒精行业盯上的增加，女性越来越多地参与酒精使用。我认为女性也开始引领潮流，并提供一些其他方式来思考如何减少饮酒并重新评估酒精在你生活中的使用，这绝对是太棒了。我经常认为患有酒精使用障碍的人是那种一直过度饮酒的人。我想我并不孤单。但我读过克利夫兰诊所的一篇文章，说酒精使用障碍的定义是尽管有负面后果却无法停止。而这个门槛可能是一晚一杯或一周一杯。所以这对我来说非常有趣，它不一定是指身体依赖。它不是指你每天喝10杯。它可能只是意味着你需要，你觉得你需要每晚喝那杯红酒。是的，完全正确。我认为我们社会的另一个问题是，我喜欢
what I love about the sober curious movement is people who are not at that severe end of what we think of as someone who has a problem, you know. And so we we kind of have this vision in our culture, our society, that if you're drinking 10 drinks a day and having terrible problems, then you have an alcohol use disorder and you can never drink again. And everyone else can drink as much as they want. And really, that's that, that idea that there's this us or them that, that people either are addicted to alcohol and physically dependent on alcohol or they can drink as much as they want because they're not physically addicted. That whole notion is completely wrong based on the science. So what the science tells us and years of science has shown is that there is really a continuum. And so people
“清醒好奇”运动的一点是，那些并没有达到我们认为“有问题”的严重程度的人。所以我们在文化和社会中有一种愿景，认为如果你每天喝10杯酒并遇到严重问题，那么你就有酒精使用障碍，你永远不能再喝酒了。而其他人可以随心所欲地喝多少就喝多少。实际上，那种认为存在“我们”或“他们”的观念，即人们要么对酒精上瘾并产生身体依赖，要么可以随心所欲地喝，因为他们没有身体成瘾，这种观念基于科学是完全错误的。科学告诉我们，多年来的科学研究表明，这确实是一个连续体。所以人们
who can drink a lot of alcohol don't necessarily have symptoms of alcohol use disorder. And some people who drink very little do have symptoms of alcohol use disorder. And so, you know, the thing that I use as my kind of rubric, so there's obviously a longer assessment. the diagnostic system to diagnose someone with an alcohol use disorder, which I'm sure the Cleveland Clinic outlined, which largely does revolve around kind of consequences of drinking, as well as having a tolerance and needing alcohol in your life. I would really kind of simplify it to, you know, I see if alcohol is starting to cause problems in your life, then alcohol is causing problems in your life. And you should take a look at it. You know, it doesn't mean that you are,
即使喝很多酒也不一定有酒精使用障碍的症状。而有些人喝得很少却有酒精使用障碍的症状。所以，你知道，我用作准则的东西——当然有一个更长的评估系统来诊断某人是否患有酒精使用障碍，我相信克利夫兰诊所概述过，它主要围绕饮酒的后果，以及产生耐受性和生活中需要酒精。我会真正将其简化为：如果酒精开始在你的生活中造成问题，那么酒精就在你的生活中造成了问题。你应该审视一下它。你知道，这并不意味着你
have a severe alcohol use disorder, it means that, yeah, alcohol is maybe not fit into your life the way you want it to. And it might be worth taking a look or reducing your drinking. And then if reducing your drinking is hard, if you're unable to reduce your drinking, if you're finding yourself really wanting a drink and really struggling to not drink, then that might be a sign that it's time to get some help or reach out to get some help. Yeah. And the terminology, I think, is important. And then you and I touch on this when we had our initial call about the episode, is that, and you were, you know, you corrected me when I said alcoholic and you said it's someone with an alcohol use disorder. Can you talk about the importance of how we, you know, label someone and how we describe someone who has an alcohol use disorder and getting away from that term alcoholic? Yeah, definitely.
患有严重的酒精使用障碍，这意味着酒精可能没有以你想要的方式融入你的生活。这可能值得一看或减少你的饮酒量。然后，如果减少饮酒很困难，如果你无法减少饮酒，如果你发现自己非常想喝酒，并且在努力不喝酒时感到非常挣扎，那么这可能是一个信号，表明是时候寻求一些帮助或寻求帮助了。是的。而且我认为术语很重要。你和我谈论这一集时提到了这一点，你纠正了我，当我称某人为“酒鬼”时，你说那是“患有酒精使用障碍的人”。你能谈谈我们如何标记某人，以及我们如何描述患有酒精使用障碍的人，并摆脱“酒鬼”这个词的重要性吗？是的，绝对可以。
And thank you for raising the question of terminology. It's really so important. And one of the biggest reasons that alcohol and other drug use disorders are so difficult in our society is the stigma associated with them. And one thing that perpetuates stigma that we know perpetuates stigma is labels. And the term alcoholic, and I wish you could see me using air quotes because I'm using air quotes around that term. The term alcoholic is very pathologizing and stigmatizing. And in fact, there's been research on this idea that even seeing that term, term makes people, general population, feel more negatively towards a person if they are labeled
感谢你提出术语的问题。这真的很重要。酒精和其他药物使用障碍在我们社会中如此难以处理的最大原因之一是与之相关的污名。而我们知道，助长污名的一件事就是标签。术语“酒鬼”，我希望你能看到我用手指比出引号，因为我正在给这个词加上引号。“酒鬼”这个词非常病态化和污名化。事实上，关于这个想法已经有了研究，即使看到这个词，也会让普通大众如果一个人被贴上这个标签，就会对那个人产生更负面的感觉。
with that term. And even bigger concern. So there's a stigma concern and it really is associated with negative pathologizing views of a person that the person is inherently flawed if that term is applied to them versus what we really should be thinking about is this is someone who has had problems with alcohol. This is an individual who maybe has had difficulty in controlling their alcohol use or has had problems associated with alcohol might be criteria for alcohol use disorder. So there's those problems with the term. Another problem with the term and generally is that it really creates an either or that you either, again, using air quotes, are an alcoholic or you're not. And that is where I think
甚至更令人担忧的是。所以存在污名化的问题，它确实与对一个人的负面病态化观点相关联，即如果这个词被应用到他们身上，这个人本质上是有缺陷的，而我们真正应该思考的是：这是一个在酒精方面遇到问题的人。这是一个在控制酒精使用方面可能有困难，或者有与酒精相关的问题，可能符合酒精使用障碍标准的人。所以这个词存在这些问题。关于这个词的另一个问题是，它确实创造了一种“非此即彼”的局面，即你要么——再次使用引号——是酒鬼，要么不是。我认为
another big problem-wise, because actually alcohol use disorder occurs on a continuum, as I was saying. So people have a range of severity of symptoms, and there really isn't a line at which you are a, quote-unquote, alcoholic versus when you're not. People meet criteria for just one or two symptoms of alcohol use disorder might still be experiencing problems related to their alcohol, might still benefit from reducing their alcohol use, might still benefit from seeking treatment. But because, Because of this false notion that there is a line at which you become a quote unquote alcoholic versus not, by perpetuating that false notion, we actually, people don't get the help that they need early on. And alcohol is a progressive neuroadaptive disorder. Alcohol use disorder is a progressive neuroadaptive disorder. So the more you drink, the more you drink over time, the more your brain adapts to having alcohol on board. So the longer you go without recognizing that there's a problem with your alcohol use, the more your brain is going to become disrupted by the use of alcohol.
这是另一个大问题，因为实际上酒精使用障碍是发生在一个连续体上的，正如我所说。所以人们有不同严重程度的症状，并没有一条线能划分出你是否是所谓的“酒鬼”。符合一两个酒精使用障碍症状标准的人，可能仍然在经历与酒精相关的问题，可能仍然会从减少酒精使用中受益，可能仍然会从寻求治疗中受益。但是因为这种关于存在一条线能划分你是否是所谓的“酒鬼”的错误观念，通过延续这种错误的观念，我们实际上导致人们没有在早期得到他们需要的帮助。酒精是一种进行性神经适应性障碍。酒精使用障碍是一种进行性神经适应性障碍。所以你喝得越多，随着时间的推移喝得越多，你的大脑就越适应酒精的存在。因此，你越晚意识到自己的酒精使用有问题，你的大脑就会越受到酒精使用的破坏。
So if we could kind of get away from this rock bottom, there's a line at which you have an alcohol use disorder to a perspective of, no, this is a health behavior that occurs on a continuum. It's not something you want to wait until you're so badly beaten by the disorder before you seek help. and so I would love for a society to just move away from this binary us or them. There is a problem where there's not a problem in more towards, again, seeing alcohol as a behavior where we can engage in it at low levels and still experience problems. And then when we're experiencing problems from alcohol, that's a signal that it might be time to reduce your drinking, to reevaluate your relationship with drinking and possibly seek help. If you are questioning your relationship with alcohol, what should you do? What are the first steps you should take?
所以如果我们能摆脱这种“触底反弹”、存在一条线能划分你是否有酒精使用障碍的观点，转向一种观点，即：不，这是一种发生在连续体上的健康行为。这不是那种你想等到被这种障碍折磨得体无完肤才寻求帮助的事情。所以我希望社会能摆脱这种二元的“我们”或“他们”。存在问题或不存在问题，更多地转向将酒精视为一种行为，我们可以低水平地参与其中，但仍然会遇到问题。而当我们因酒精遇到问题时，那是一个信号，表明可能是时候减少饮酒，重新评估你与饮酒的关系，并可能寻求帮助了。如果你正在质疑你与酒精的关系，你应该怎么做？你应该采取的第一步是什么？
Excellent question. So the first step, I think that's really important is to just know what you're drinking. So to pay attention to what you're drinking and actually log what you're drinking, just like we would keep track of a food log. If we were on a diet, we would keep track of what we're eating. If we're thinking about changing our drinking, I think the first step is to keep track of what we're drinking. And that also includes knowing what's in a drink. So a lot of people don't even recognize what to log because so many of our drinks now are actually more than a single state. standard drink. So a standard drink is 14 grams of pure alcohol and how that translates is roughly a 5 ounce glass of 12% wine, 12 ounce glass or can or bottle of regular beer at about 5% alcohol and about 1.5 ounces of 80 proof liquor. So what that means, though, is that a lot of us, when we're drinking, especially in bars or other places where we're not controlling what we're pouring, we're often getting actually larger than that in standard drink units. So for example, if you go to a restaurant and a lot of higher-end restaurants do these just absolutely massive pores of wine that are like nine-ounce pores. And so that's almost two standard drinks,
很好的问题。所以第一步，我认为非常重要的一点是了解你在喝什么。即关注你在喝什么，并实际记录下你在喝什么，就像我们会记录饮食日志一样。如果我们正在节食，我们会记录我们吃的东西。如果我们正在考虑改变我们的饮酒习惯，我认为第一步是记录我们喝的东西。这也包括知道一杯酒里有什么。所以很多人甚至不知道该记录什么，因为我们现在的许多饮料实际上超过了一份标准饮酒量。一份标准饮酒量是14克纯酒精，换算下来大约是5盎司12%的红酒，12盎司约5%酒精的普通啤酒，以及约1.5盎司80度烈酒。但这意味着，我们许多人在喝酒时，特别是在酒吧或其他我们无法控制倒酒量的地方，我们经常得到的量实际上超过了标准饮酒单位。例如，如果你去一家餐厅，许多高档餐厅会倒出非常巨大的红酒，大约9盎司。所以这几乎是两份标准饮酒量，
if it's a 12% glass of wine. And so what that means is you think you're just having two drinks at the restaurant, but you're actually having four, almost four drinks. And as I noted earlier, are four drinks for a woman is considered heavy drinking. So your two glasses of wine actually corresponds to a heavy drinking event. Similarly, for the microbrewery movement, there's microbreweries everywhere, and these microbreweries and brew pubs, they have pretty high alcohol content beer. And so, for example, if you have a 16 ounce pint of an India Pale Ale, then it might actually be closer to one and a half to two standard drinks, not the one drink that you think you're having. So what we encourage people to do is just become more aware of what they're drinking,
如果是一杯12%的红酒的话。这意味着你以为你在餐厅只喝了两杯，但实际上你喝了四杯，几乎四杯。正如我之前提到的，女性喝四杯被认为是酗酒。所以你的两杯红酒实际上对应于一次酗酒事件。同样，对于精酿啤酒运动，到处都是精酿啤酒厂，这些精酿啤酒厂和酒吧，它们的啤酒酒精含量相当高。所以，例如，如果你喝了一品脱16盎司的印度淡色艾尔啤酒，那么它实际上可能更接近一份半到两份标准饮酒量，而不是你认为的一杯。所以我们鼓励人们做的是，只是变得更了解他们在喝什么，
what they're putting in in their glasses and how much alcohol they're consuming and then keeping track of that, logging that over time. And so just paying attention to what they're drinking over time. And then maybe evaluating where could you make some changes? Where could you maybe decide to insert, you know, I don't have to have drinks every night of the week. I'm going to have, you know, one sober day where I'm not going to drink any alcohol and try implementing that or maybe deciding that, you know, I typically have two to three drinks on Monday nights and I really would get by well with just one drink on a Monday night. And so looking at places in your schedule of drinking of where you could maybe cut back or reduce your drinking or have a abstinence day
他们在杯子里放了什么，以及他们摄入了多少酒精，然后记录下来，随着时间的推移记录下来。所以只是关注他们随着时间的推移喝了什么。然后也许评估一下你可以在哪里做出一些改变？你可以在哪里决定插入，你知道，我不必一周七天都喝酒。我要有，你知道，一个清醒日，我不喝任何酒精，并尝试实施它，或者也许决定，你知道，我通常在周一晚上喝两到三杯，我其实只喝一杯周一晚上就能过得很好。所以看看你饮酒时间表中的哪些地方你可以减少或缩减你的饮酒量，或者有一个禁酒日，
where you're not drinking at all. And then from there, if you're noticing that you're having trouble with living by your own guidelines and setting your own rules, if you're having trouble sticking to that, let's say you're, you know, two drinks a night that you were going to have, you wanted to make it a one drink a night and you can't do it, you know, that you keep failing or that you're not successful in cutting down or having that one abstinence day a week, for example, that might be an indication that there's something going on here. And in fact, that's a symptom of alcohol use disorder is repeated attempts. at cutting down that are unsuccessful. And so if you're having trouble cutting down, this might be a time
你根本不喝酒。然后从那里开始，如果你注意到你在遵守自己的准则和设定自己的规则方面有困难，如果你在坚持这一点方面有困难，假设你，你知道，你本来打算每晚喝两杯，你想改成每晚一杯，但你做不到，你知道，你不断失败，或者你在减少饮酒或每周有一个禁酒日方面不成功，例如，这可能是一个迹象，表明这里发生了一些事情。事实上，这是酒精使用障碍的一个症状，即反复尝试
when you start looking for more support. And that might involve looking online for an online support group among people who are reducing their drinking, maybe reaching out to a friend and seeing if a friend would be interested in making the same change that you're making, kind of like an exercise buddy, a drinking reduction buddy, where both of you are going to decide that when you meet for your book club, instead of having three glasses of wine at book club, you're going to have one glass of wine at book club. So enrolling some social support in making these changes can be really helpful. If that's not working, then potentially seeking out some sort of mutual support group, such as Alcoholics Anonymous or Smart Recovery or Women for Sobriety, there's a lot of different
减少饮酒但未成功。所以如果你在减少饮酒方面有困难，这可能是一个时候，当你开始寻找更多支持。这可能包括在网上寻找一个由正在减少饮酒的人组成的在线支持小组，也许联系一个朋友，看看朋友是否有兴趣做出和你一样的改变，就像锻炼伙伴一样，一个减少饮酒的伙伴，你们俩都决定，当你们去读书俱乐部时，不再喝三杯红酒，而是喝一杯红酒。所以招募一些社会支持来做出这些改变真的很有帮助。如果这不起作用，那么可能寻求某种互助小组，例如“匿名戒酒互助会”或“智能恢复”或“女性清醒”，有很多不同的
online groups that are geared towards helping people reduce their drinking, providing kind of social and peer support for that. And if that's not working or that doesn't feel comfortable for you, then another option can be talking to your primary care provider. So we actually have effective medications for alcohol use disorder that primary care providers can prescribe that are very effective. One of my favorites, particularly for people who don't want to stop drinking altogether, but who are interested in reducing their drinking, is naltrexone. Nelotrexone can be prescribed by a primary care provider.
在线小组旨在帮助人们减少饮酒，为之提供某种社会和同伴支持。如果这不起作用或者让你感到不舒服，那么另一个选择可以是与你的初级保健医生交谈。所以我们实际上有针对酒精使用障碍的有效药物，初级保健医生可以开具这些药物，它们非常有效。我最喜欢的药物之一，特别是对于那些不想完全戒酒，但有兴趣减少饮酒的人，是纳曲酮。纳曲酮可以由初级保健医生开具。
It has pretty minimal side effects and has helped people kind of take the edge off drinking where they don't want to drink as much and they might have less craving for alcohol. So instead of having five drinks, they'll be okay with having two and they won't want to keep drinking. So it kind of helps people put the brakes on their drinking when they're drinking. And so that's a great medication for individuals who just really want a little bit of extra support in reducing their drinking. We also have medications for people who are more geared towards abstinence and supporting abstinence. So one of those medications is called a campersate. And a campersate can help people who are wanting to maintain not drinking at all, particularly for people who are maybe
它的副作用非常小，而且已经帮助人们在饮酒时有所节制，让他们不想喝那么多，对酒精的渴望也可能会减少。所以，他们本来要喝五杯，现在喝两杯就够了，也不会想继续喝下去。因此，它在人们饮酒时起到了一种“刹车”的作用。对于那些确实希望在减少饮酒方面获得额外支持的人来说，这是一种很好的药物。我们也有针对那些更倾向于戒酒并支持戒酒的人的药物。其中一种药物叫做阿坎酸（Acamprosate）。阿坎酸可以帮助那些想要完全戒酒的人，特别是对于那些可能
struggling with not drinking as far as having a lot of withdrawal symptoms or negative moods coming in. We also have really great behavioral therapies that work for alcohol use disorder. So I would also encourage people to potentially seek out a treatment provider who's a therapist or counselor or social worker who's trained in delivering brief behavioral treatment. for alcohol use disorder. And these can be as short as two sessions of just looking at your alcohol use with a provider to talk about your alcohol use, to talk about kind of where you want to make changes, how you might make some of those changes, kind of problem solving about what's
在戒酒过程中感到挣扎，比如出现大量戒断症状或负面情绪的人。我们还有非常出色的行为疗法，对酒精使用障碍非常有效。因此，我也鼓励人们去寻找一位治疗师、咨询师或社会工作者，他们受过提供简短行为治疗的培训，专门针对酒精使用障碍。这些治疗可以非常简短，只需与治疗师进行两次会谈，审视你的饮酒习惯，讨论你想在哪些方面做出改变，如何做出这些改变，以及解决阻碍你改变的问题，
getting in the way, or a longer treatment. So anywhere from four sessions to maybe eight sessions of treatment with a provider where you look a little bit more closely on some of the reasons why you're drinking, maybe kind of treating some of the underlying problems. So a lot of people, like I said before, are drinking for reasons to feel better, to relieve pain, to relieve negative moods, to reduce social anxiety. And so getting some treatment to support those underlying causes can really help in supporting people and reducing their drinking because they're not turning to alcohol to deal with those problems. And you use mindful, based treatment for addiction relapse prevention in your work. Can you explain what that is and how
或者进行更长期的治疗。比如四到八次的治疗，与治疗师一起更深入地探讨你饮酒的一些原因，或许还能解决一些潜在的问题。正如我之前所说，很多人饮酒是为了感觉更好、缓解疼痛、缓解负面情绪或减轻社交焦虑。因此，针对这些潜在原因进行治疗，确实可以帮助人们减少饮酒，因为他们不再需要通过酒精来应对这些问题。你在工作中使用了基于正念的成瘾复发预防治疗。你能解释一下那是什么以及它有多
effective it is? Yes. And so I failed to mention our own treatment program and talking about treatment options. Yeah. So mindfulness based treatments we've been working with for almost 20 years now. And it's an incredibly effective treatment for alcohol use disorder and other drug use disorders for getting at some of the kind of root causes of addiction and really looking at and being aware of how our mind works and really being able to come to terms with ourselves and with our minds and with our bodies and to just increase our awareness of kind of the stressors of daily life, of other comorbid problems that we have. So pain, anxiety, depression, to really be able to sit with those experiences and be with them without turning to alcohol. And so really being able
有效吗？是的。我在谈论治疗方案时忘了提到我们自己的治疗项目。是的，我们使用基于正念的治疗已经快20年了。对于酒精使用障碍和其他药物使用障碍，这是一种极其有效的治疗方法，它能触及成瘾的一些根源，真正审视并意识到我们的思维是如何运作的，真正能够与自己、与我们的思想和身体达成和解，并提高我们对日常生活压力源以及我们所患的其他共病问题的认识。比如疼痛、焦虑、抑郁，能够真正地与这些体验共处，而不求助于酒精。所以，真正能够
to experience distress in the moment and sit with that. distress and to do so with acceptance and without judgment. And so it's a really helpful training program for, we even say retraining the brain to basically retrain the brain to be able to be with the present moment. And our society is very much not in the present moment. And oftentimes we're reaching for things or we're living in the past. And we very rarely really relish and appreciate and savior the present moment experience. And alcohol actually takes us way out of the present moment, right? It changes our experience. And so we, in mindfulness-based treatment, train people to reconnect with, be open to accept and non-judgmentally be aware of the present moment experience.
在当下体验痛苦并与这种痛苦共处，并且做到接纳而不评判。这是一个非常有帮助的训练项目，我们甚至称之为“重塑大脑”，基本上就是重新训练大脑，使其能够与当下时刻共处。我们的社会非常不注重当下。我们往往在追求某些东西，或者生活在过去。我们很少真正享受、欣赏和品味当下的体验。而酒精实际上把我们从当下带走了，对吧？它改变了我们的体验。因此，在基于正念的治疗中，我们训练人们重新连接、开放、接纳并以非评判的态度意识到当下的体验。
And in doing so, can help change their relationship to themselves, the world, but also their relationships with alcohol and drug. Because alcohol and drugs can really, again, in the short-term get us out of the moment when the moment is hard. And so mindfulness-based treatments really retrain us to be okay with the moment even when it's hard and not reach for alcohol and drugs. And of all the treatment options you mentioned, from tracking to the self-help books, to the medication, to the mindfulness treatment, is there research showing what might work best, or is it particular to the individual? It's really particular to the individual. What we know is that for some individuals just tracking their alcohol use will result in pretty drastic reductions
这样做可以帮助他们改变与自己、与世界的关系，也能改变他们与酒精和药物的关系。因为酒精和药物确实可以在短期内让我们在困难时刻逃避当下。所以，基于正念的治疗真正重新训练我们，让我们即使在困难时刻也能安然处之，而不去寻求酒精和药物。在你提到的所有治疗方案中，从记录饮酒量到自助书籍，再到药物和正念治疗，是否有研究表明哪种方法最有效，还是因人而异？这确实因人而异。我们知道，对于某些人来说，仅仅记录他们的饮酒量就会导致饮酒量大幅减少
in their drinking. Just seeing how much you're drinking can be really helpful to reduce your drinking. For other individuals, particularly people who've been drinking for a very long time, who might be more physiologically dependent and have neuroadaptations from drinking, they probably will benefit more from probably a combination of medication and a mindfulness-based treatment, potentially even having a detoxification in there to kind of clear alcohol from their system. So it really depends on the individual and individual range of severity. I think for most people who are questioning and kind of in this less severe range, I think even just tracking their drinking, having some social support around reducing their drinking,
。仅仅看到自己喝了多少酒，对于减少饮酒就非常有帮助。对于其他人，特别是那些长期饮酒、生理上可能更依赖酒精并因饮酒产生神经适应的人，他们可能更受益于药物和基于正念治疗的结合，甚至可能需要进行排毒以清除体内的酒精。所以这确实取决于个人以及个人的严重程度。我认为对于大多数处于这种较轻程度、还在犹豫的人来说，我认为仅仅是记录他们的饮酒量，在减少饮酒方面获得一些社会支持，
even just talking to their primary care provider could be really helpful in reducing their drinking, and that's going to be most people. How does taking a break from alcohol benefit you mentally and physically? I mean, does it need to be a set period of time, or what are your thoughts on that? Excellent question. So what we know is that alcohol is toxic. It actually requires work from the liver to clear it out, and it impacts actually all systems of the body.
甚至只是与他们的初级保健医生谈谈，都可能对减少饮酒非常有帮助，而这适用于大多数人。戒酒一段时间在精神和身体上有什么好处？我的意思是，需要设定一个固定的时间段吗，或者你对此有什么看法？这是一个很好的问题。我们知道酒精是有毒的。它实际上需要肝脏努力工作才能将其清除，而且它实际上会影响身体的所有系统。
It impacts the brain as well. So any reduction in drinking, our latest work is showing that any reduction, in drinking is associated with mental and physical benefits. And so even reducing by one drink a day or reducing from four drinks to two drinks, you're going to see benefits. For people who take a longer break from alcohol, let's say a week or two weeks or up to four weeks, so people who kind of complete one of these dry January months or sober October months or kind of take a longer break from alcohol, they might see even larger improvements. So people report when you take a longer break from alcohol, that you'll have better sleeping patterns is one of the first ones that
它也会影响大脑。因此，我们最新的研究表明，任何饮酒量的减少都与精神和身体健康益处相关。所以即使每天少喝一杯，或者从四杯减少到两杯，你也会看到好处。对于那些戒酒时间较长的人，比如一周、两周甚至长达四周，也就是那些完成了“干一月”（Dry January）、“清醒十月”（Sober October）或者戒酒时间更长的人，他们可能会看到更大的改善。所以人们报告说，当你戒酒时间较长时，你会拥有更好的睡眠模式，这是人们注意到的第一件事，
people notice that they sleep better. Alcohol does interfere with sleep in a number of different ways. People report their skin looks better and that they just feel better. They have more energy. Of course, it's not just the alcohol, right? If you're reducing your alcohol and then you're sleeping better, you're going to have more energy, right? So it's kind of a cascade of effects from even stopping for a short time. But I also really like to reiterate, that you don't necessarily have to stop for an entire month or even stop for several weeks. Even reducing your drinking is likely to result in some benefit, albeit a little bit more subtle than what people report when they stop drinking altogether.
他们睡得更好。酒精确实以多种方式干扰睡眠。人们报告说他们的皮肤看起来更好，感觉也更好。他们有更多的精力。当然，这不仅仅是因为酒精，对吧？如果你减少了饮酒，睡眠质量提高了，你自然会有更多的精力，对吧？所以即使只是短时间停止饮酒，也会产生一系列连锁反应。但我还要重申，你不一定非要停止一个月甚至几周。即使减少饮酒也可能会带来一些好处，尽管比人们完全戒酒时报告的效果要微妙一些。
And overall, what we know is going back to what we started saying at the beginning of the podcast around any reduction, you know, any increase in drinking is associated with worse health outcomes, including mental health and physical health. and any reduction in drinking is associated with better health outcomes. And so in the long run, any reductions you can do is going to be good for your health and well-being. And it seems like a lot of people understand this. You know, as you mentioned, the end of the year holiday time, people feel like they are
总的来说，我们知道回到播客开头所说的，任何饮酒量的增加都与更差的健康结果相关，包括心理健康和身体健康。而任何饮酒量的减少都与更好的健康结果相关。因此，从长远来看，你能做的任何减少饮酒的行为都对你的健康和福祉有益。似乎很多人都理解这一点。正如你提到的，年底假期期间，人们觉得自己在很多方面
overdoing it in a lot of different ways. So that's why you see a lot of people participate in dry January, which we've recently ended. Do you think that's a good way to have that crowdsourcing effect of a lot of different people you know are all trying to get through the month without any alcohol. Definitely. And the other thing it does is it creates a because there is a movement behind it, it creates a very natural and socially acceptable kind of statement around not drinking that a lot of people can be like, oh, okay, that's kind of cool. What is that? I recently actually was at a work event with several
做得过火了。所以这就是为什么你会看到很多人参加“干一月”活动，我们最近刚刚结束。你认为这是一种利用众包效应的好方法吗？让很多你认识的人都在尝试一个月不喝任何酒精饮料。绝对是。它带来的另一件事是，因为它背后有一场运动，它创造了一种关于不喝酒的非常自然且社会可接受的声明，很多人会觉得，哦，好吧，这挺酷的。那是什么？我最近实际上参加了一个工作活动，有几个人
people and it was in January and, you know, we offered a drink to one of the people in attendance. And the person said, actually, I'm doing dry January. And it was so liberating to hear someone say that. And, and, you know, then that person just felt really comfortable not drinking the rest of the night because he made a social proclamation that he was doing dry January. And it didn't have to be like this weird, you know, really big deal that he was stopping drinking forever, that he was, you know, kind of just out of treatment or some sort of other stigmatizing kind of scary notion. It's just like, yeah, I'm doing dry January. I'm not drinking this month. And it's fine. And so I love that about it. create this crowdsource of support. I know personally I did dry January years ago and four of my
在场，当时是一月份，你知道，我们给其中一位参加者提供了酒。那个人说，其实我正在参加“干一月”。听到有人这么说真是太令人释怀了。而且，你知道，那个人在那天剩下的时间里感到非常自在，没有喝酒，因为他做了一个社交声明，说他正在参加“干一月”。这不需要像那种奇怪的、非常重大的事情，比如他永远戒酒了，或者他刚从治疗中心出来，或者其他某种带有污名化的、可怕的概念。这就像是，是的，我正在参加“干一月”。我这个月不喝酒。这没问题。所以我喜欢这一点。创造这种众包支持。我知道我个人几年前参加过“干一月”，我和我的四个
friends and I, we all did it together. And we would even actually go to the same bars that we would go to. We would go to each other's houses. We would still hang out socially, but we would do so without alcohol. And because we were doing it together, it really, it did that crowdsourcing effect of just not feeling left out and not feeling like you were missing out. That said, I think one thing to be aware of is that abruptly stopping alcohol when you're severely dependent on alcohol is actually deadly. So withdrawing from alcohol is lethal for people who are consuming a lot of alcohol. So what I would say for someone who is very severely dependent on alcohol, who's physiologically very dependent on alcohol, who is drinking many, many drinks a day every single day to stop abruptly
朋友一起参加了。我们甚至会去我们平时去的酒吧。我们会去彼此家里。我们仍然会进行社交活动，但我们不喝酒。因为我们是一起做的，它确实产生了那种众包效应，让你不会感到被排斥，也不会觉得错过了什么。话虽如此，我认为有一点需要注意，那就是如果你严重依赖酒精，突然停止饮酒实际上是致命的。所以对于那些饮酒量很大的人来说，戒酒是致命的。因此，对于那些严重依赖酒精、生理上非常依赖酒精、每天都要喝很多很多杯酒的人，突然停止饮酒
could have health risks. And so I would encourage anyone who's drinking at that level and wants to try dry January to do so under the care of a medical physician and with awareness of some of the health risks of stopping drinking abruptly. Yeah, that's very important to share because I think, like you said, people need to make sure that they are taking care of their health, but also doing it safely. Exactly. And actually, speaking of that, another piece is if you do do dry January or
可能会有健康风险。所以我鼓励任何处于这种饮酒水平并想尝试“干一月”的人，在医生的护理下进行，并意识到突然停止饮酒的一些健康风险。是的，分享这一点非常重要，因为我认为，正如你所说，人们需要确保他们照顾好自己的健康，同时也要安全地进行。没错。事实上，说到这一点，另一件事是，如果你确实参加了“干一月”或者
or if you do sober October coming up, or you decide to take a break from drinking, then it's also important to know that your tolerance for alcohol is going to go away pretty quickly. And so it's not a great idea to, like, February 1st, go out and have a bender of an evening where you're drinking a ton of alcohol because you're at risk of overdosing.
或者你即将参加“清醒十月”，或者你决定戒酒一段时间，那么同样重要的是要知道，你对酒精的耐受力会很快消失。所以，在2月1日那天出去狂饮，喝下大量的酒精并不是一个好主意，因为你有酒精中毒的风险。
So kind of both things are true, like the extreme, you know, going from a lot of alcohol use to nothing, that's going to put you at risk of withdrawal, going from no alcohol use to a lot of, drinking is going to put you at risk of overdose. And so just being aware of kind of those risks around a sober period of kind of tapering to sobriety if you're going to go to sobriety and then definitely not returning to drinking what you used to drink after a period of sobriety because your body will not be able to process it as much as it used to. Thank you so much for that very
所以这两点都是事实，比如极端地从大量饮酒到完全不喝，这会让你面临戒断风险；从完全不喝酒到大量饮酒，会让你面临酒精中毒的风险。因此，只要意识到戒酒期间的这些风险，如果你打算戒酒，就要采取循序渐进的方式，而且在戒酒一段时间后，绝对不要恢复到以前的饮酒量，因为你的身体将无法像以前那样处理它。非常感谢你提供这些非常有
insightful information, Dr. Wickwith. I think our listeners will really appreciate the tips you've given them and also the importance of staying safe, whether you decide to give up alcohol completely or if you do give alcohol completely and maybe want to start trying again, I think it's important for people to understand the health risks and what they need to do to keep themselves healthy. And you've offered a lot of really wonderful information about how people can take a better look at their drinking if they feel that that's needed in their lives. Thank you. Thank you for having me.
见解的信息，Wickwith博士。我想我们的听众会非常感谢你给他们的建议，以及保持安全的重要性，无论你决定完全戒酒，还是如果你完全戒酒后可能想再次尝试，我认为人们了解健康风险以及他们需要做什么来保持健康非常重要。你提供了很多非常棒的信息，关于如果人们觉得有必要，如何更好地审视自己的饮酒习惯。谢谢。谢谢你的邀请。
It's been great. And for links to resources, you can visit our website, speakingof psychology.org, or Check the link in the episode notes. Before we go, just a reminder that we want to hear from you. You can email your comments and ideas to speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's speaking of psychology, all one word, dot org. And please consider giving us a rating in iTunes. We'd really appreciate it.
这很棒。如需资源链接，您可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org，或查看剧集说明中的链接。在离开之前，提醒一下我们想听听您的意见。您可以将您的评论和想法通过电子邮件发送至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是 speaking of psychology，全部连在一起，点 org。请考虑在 iTunes 上给我们评分。我们将不胜感激。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thanks for listening. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的往期节目。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是美国心理学会的 Caitlin Luna。感谢收听。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。